bernie mac tweed trang sage stallone
these actors and more were sadly all
taken from us too soon keep watching to
find out which actors you may not have
realized had died
one of the original kings of comedy next
to cedric the entertainer dl hughley and
steve harvey bernie mac built his hugely
successful career through a stand-up
routine heavily influenced by richard
pryor that in and of itself isn't
unusual but mack used that cornerstone
to build a presence and style that was
uniquely his own i never watch what
somebody else does it does not matter
bernie mac got to do his thing
that hard work paid off in hollywood
with a series of high profile roles many
might recognize mack as ice cube's
neighbor pastor clever in the movie
friday he'd go on to star in charlie's
angels full throttle ocean's 11
transformers and more and also headlined
a sitcom loosely based on his own
experiences called the bernie mac show
during the last years of his life max
suffered from sarcoidosis which heavily
affected his lungs and he succumbed to
pneumonia complications on august 9 2008
at the age of 50.
harold ramus was 69 when he passed away
from an autoimmune disease in 2014 which
in and of itself might have come as a
surprise to many of the film fans who
watched him in 80s classics like stripes
national lampoon's vacation and
ghostbusters a talented director and
screenwriter as well as a frequent
fixture in some of the biggest comedy
hits of the decade reimus behind the
scenes talents helped bring us groundhog
day and caddyshack among many others in
fact he jumped back and forth between
either side of the cameras throughout
his career co-writing both of the
ghostbusters movies as well as stripes
although few fans knew he was ill raymus
struggled with the side effects of his
infection for years he had to learn how
to walk all over again after contracting
autoimmune inflammatory vasculitis in
2010 and suffered a relapse the
following year his final on-screen
appearance came in the 2009 comedy year
one
a veteran of stage and screen who
amassed a distinguished career spanning
decades richard harris notched arguably
his highest profile role late in his
career courtesy of the blockbuster harry
potter film franchise in two of his
final screen appearances harris played
potter's beloved headmaster albus
dumbledore in the first two installments
of the blockbuster film franchise the
sorcerer's stone and the chamber of
secrets although he'll always be
dumbledore to generations of potter
loving fans outside of hogwarts harris
compiled multiple careers worth of
impressive credits and honors
he was an accomplished singer actor
director writer producer and songwriter
who won grammy and golden globe awards
for his work on 15 different albums and
more than 70 films including camelot the
guns of navarone gulliver's travels
patriot games unforgiven gladiator and
the count of monte cristo after being
diagnosed with hodgkin's disease harris
died on october 25th 2002 at the age of
72.
best known for playing the young carol
anne from the movie poltergeist heather
o'rourke skyrocketed to instant fame as
the sweet young girl that terrified
audiences after being sucked into the
television set in fact she may have
played the part a little too well
although o'rourke racked up an
impressive list of credits after her
breakthrough performance as carol anne
she remained tied to the franchise in
the public's mind and she was one of a
very small number of original cast
members that remained with the movie
series until its conclusion with 1988's
poltergeist iii if you've seen the final
movie you may notice that heather's
cheeks appear very puffy and although
audiences didn't know it at the time it
was a reaction to the medication she was
taking for crohn's disease with which
she was misdiagnosed
tragedy struck on february 1st 1988 when
heather suffered from cardiac arrest
while undergoing a surgery for a bowel
obstruction at the tender age of 12.
tui trang was best known for her work as
the original yellow ranger on mighty
morphin power rangers but unlike a lot
of actors who start out in genre tv she
seemed in no danger of being typecast in
fact she was developing what seemed like
a potentially promising career after
leaving the show trang jumped right into
feature work landing roles in a pair of
movies released in 1996 the dark drama
the crow city of angels and the leslie
nielsen comedy spy hard clearly trang
had enough chops to tackle work from a
variety of genres but sadly she never
had a chance to fulfill that potential
she was killed in a car accident at the
age of 27 in 2001 after the driver lost
control of the vehicle and it plunged
over a guardrail on california's
interstate 5. emergency medical
personnel tried getting trang to the
hospital but she died in transit the
result of massive internal injuries
one of hollywood's all-time ultimate
that guy actors taylor negron compiled a
truly compressive list of classic screen
credits without ever becoming a
household name although he tended to be
on screen for no more than a few moments
at a time negron's deadpan delivery made
him a fan favorite among film
aficionados of the 80s and a standout in
pictures like fast times at richmond
high and better off dead
later in his career negron made
memorable appearances on hit tv shows
like seinfeld and friends but as much
fun as he could be on screen he was even
more interesting behind the scenes in
addition to acting negron was an
acclaimed writer whose work included
published collections of short stories
as well as a trained painter whose work
was shown in multiple galleries he was
only 57 when he died in early 2015 after
a battle with liver cancer
after making a name for himself as a
professional wrestler rowdy roddy piper
branched out onto the big screen most
notably through his starring role in the
1988 cult classic they live leading that
cult john carpenter classic piper waged
war against a covert alien invasion and
coined an unforgettable catchphrase i
have come here to chew bubble gum and
kick ass
and i'm all out above them
piper's bone-crunching work in that film
helped set the tone for a busy hollywood
career full of b-movie roles and small
but unforgettable appearances on
television shows like it's always sunny
in philadelphia on the screen as well as
in the ring piper gave every performance
his all frequently elevating otherwise
forgettable material and consistently
serving as the most memorable component
of whatever project he was appearing in
he died in his sleep in 2015 after
suffering a pulmonary embolism that
triggered a heart attack
critically maligned and pretty much
ignored at the box office rocky 5 is
indisputably the least loved film of
sylvester stallone's long-running boxing
franchise take a careful look under its
cheesier elements however and you can
see the outline of a truly affecting
story about a former heavyweight champ
going broke losing his ability to box
and nearly losing his relationship with
his son to help tell the story stallone
brought in his own 14 year old son sage
to play the part of robert rocky jr
balboa in the film and young stallone's
time on the set clearly made a positive
impression after college sage continued
working in the industry in small low-key
projects carving out a career in his own
right apart from his blockbuster leading
father unfortunately sage died on july
13 2012 at the young age of 36 due to a
heart attack brought on by coronary
artery disease
long before he founded an ill-fated
amusement park using the secrets of dino
dna richard attenborough was already an
accomplished and award-winning actor
attenborough starred alongside steve
mcqueen in the great escape released in
the midst of a busy period that included
some of his most widely seen work he
also won two consecutive golden globe
awards in 1967 and 1968 for co-starring
in the sand pebbles and dr doolittle
needless to say attenborough's career
contains no shortage of highlights and
his work will no doubt be familiar to
classic film fans younger film-goers
however have their own attenborough
memories thanks to his appearance as
john hammond whose ambitions led to the
creation of jurassic park that
blockbuster made him famous to a whole
new generation but it's just one short
chapter in a life of many great
cinematic achievements that ended on
august 24th 2014 at the age of 90.
would you talk about willis
kids of the 70s and 80s and honestly
anyone who enjoys the classic sitcoms of
the era will immediately recognize the
immortal catchphrase gary coleman coined
as an adorable kid on the long-running
hit sitcom different strokes coleman's
diminutive stature helped him continue
to play younger characters throughout
much of his career and at the peak of
his fame he landed a series of film and
television roles unfortunately his
youthful looks and peak height of 4 feet
8 inches were side effects of an
autoimmune kidney disease combined with
the medications he took throughout his
life to fight the condition
work in hollywood became harder to come
by after strokes left the airwaves and
behind the scenes he underwent frequent
dialysis treatments and was forced to
undergo two kidney transplants
after a fall at his home coleman died on
may 28 2010 of an epidural hematoma at
the age of 42.
exactly where you remember esteemed
actor edward herrmann from depends on
whether you favor musicals vampire
movies medical tv shows or fast-talking
mother-daughter family dramas
hermann is probably best recognized
today for his role as pompous but
warm-hearted patriarch richard gilmore
in the series gilmore girls richard's
dry sense of humor and quiet authority
contrasted with the quick wit and
constant banter that flew between his
daughter lorelei and his granddaughter
rory and his wife emily who was played
by kelly bishop off-screen hermann and
bishop both classically trained and
meticulous about their craft were
especially close herman's wife star whom
he married in 1994 would joke that
bishop was his other wife
in hermann's final moments his family
invited bishop to say goodbye with them
before his longest running role in
gilmore girls hermann worked regularly
on tv and in movies he was nominated for
an emmy for playing a priest in the
medical drama saint elsewhere and won
one for the legal series the practice
he played franklin d roosevelt in the
1982 adaptation of annie having
previously played the president for a
mini-series and tv movie in the late 70s
and in 1987 he played a stepfather from
literal hell in the vampire movie the
lost boys
hermann died of brain cancer at age 71
on december 31 2014
in the netflix revival of gilmore girls
it was revealed that richard had also
died sparking big changes for emily in
particular
deezer dee was one of the foundational
actors on hit medical trauma er
born darren thompson he played nurse
malik mcgrath on the show's entire
15-year run appearing in 188 episodes as
often happens in real hospitals as well
as fictional ones er typically focused
on its physicians and surgeons not the
nurses but thompson was one of just a
handful of actors who appeared in every
season and his episode count makes him
the fifth most prolific member of the
large cast
outside of er thompson had a few small
parts in movies including the cult
classic comedy romy and michelle's high
school reunion and appeared in vanilla
ice's video for cool as ice
he played one of the members of a
fictional rap group in the mockumentary
movie cb4 in 1993 and also rapped for
real he released multiple records
including the full-length album delayed
but not denied in 2008 and continued
making songs until his death his final
track history can't be stopped was
released posthumously thompson started
having heart issues around 2008 telling
radar online the following year that he
had been suffering from recurrent
pneumonia and heart failure it was
discovered that he had a leaking valve
and expanded aorta which was addressed
with surgery in 2009 according to
deadline he went on to have more
operations on his heart over the next 10
years or so thompson died on january 7
2021 at the age of 55 of a suspected
heart attack
catherine justin was in her 50s when she
started working consistently in
notoriously youth-centric hollywood in
the mid-1990s
she'd start acting in 1980 after
realizing she was missing out on
following her dreams
despite her late start juicing built a
career playing one-off but always
memorable characters in hit tv series
her credits include er third rock from
the sun seinfeld roseanne the nanny
frasier buffy the vampire slayer and the
x-files to name just a few later she
would add the likes of will and grace
and grey's anatomy to that list in short
name a hit show of the 90s and 2000s and
justin probably appeared in it her most
memorable guest appearance was as a
woman who refused treatment for kidney
failure in season 1 of scrubs the
episode my old lady consistently ranks
as a fan favorite thanks in no small
part to justin's performance
unfortunately we don't really have a
choice well actually i do have a choice
certain things you never expect to come
out of a person's mouth
i think i'm ready to die
in addition to those guest roles justin
landed regular parts in two major series
she played the steely secretary to
martin sheen's president bartlett in two
seasons of the west wing combining her
talents for fast-paced drama and comedy
and nosy but occasionally helpful
neighbor karen mccluskey and desperate
housewives justin was first treated for
lung cancer in 2001 the year mild lady
aired she was undergoing treatment while
making the final season of desperate
housewives which was written into her
character's arc mccluskey died in the
season finale justin died two weeks
after that episode aired on june 2nd
2012 at the age of 72.
hugh dane's resume reads like a list of
the top sitcoms of the 90s and early
2000s he played two different characters
in the fresh prince of bel air appeared
in an episode of martin and multiple
episodes of rock he had small parts and
friends sister sister everybody hates
chris and new girl on the drama side he
played a judge in an episode of the west
wing he also appeared briefly in the
comedy movies little fockers and
bridesmaids
however dane will most likely be
remembered and missed for his role as
hank the permanently unimpressed
security guard in the office he appeared
in 22 episodes of nbc's hit mockumentary
about the inner workings and ridiculous
shenanigans in a scranton pennsylvania
paper company
dane died at the age of 75 on may 16
2018.
after his death his the office co-star
rayne wilson described him as one of the
greats so kind funny and talented on
january 1st 2021 nbc's streaming
platform peacock tweeted a video of a
cold open that never aired dedicated to
dane it showed one of jim's most
elaborate pranks on nemesis dwight
featuring dane as morpheus from the
matrix
if the blue pill is not safe to swallow
someone should tell us now
kenny baker originated one of the most
beloved characters in one of the most
popular movie franchises of all time but
you wouldn't recognize him from that
role out of costume baker is most famous
for playing r2d2 the brave and
mischievous star wars droid he was born
with dwarfism but it wasn't just baker's
height that made him perfect for the
role according to his new york times
obituary he was the only person small
enough to fit into the costume who was
also strong enough to move it
it helped that baker had been in
entertainment for years he sang danced
played instruments clowned and ice
skated in various touring companies
as he told the guardian there are
certain close-up movements only i can do
convincingly it's all about giving r2 a
personality and cgi can never really do
that
in addition to r2 baker played an ewok
in return of the jedi alongside his wife
and fellow actor eileen but the furry
violent inhabitants of the jungle planet
endor were less fun to play than to
watch thanks to the stuffy costumes it
wasn't just that they were hot the heads
were impossible to see out of when they
steamed up
the last time baker played r2 was for
revenge of the sith although he served
as a consultant on the force awakens
he also appeared in many other movies
and series including flash gordon time
bandits and amadeus he died at the age
of 81 on august 13 2016.
if you're a millennial who grew up
wishing you could have an identical twin
to swap lives with you probably remember
natasha richardson best for her role as
the extremely cool fashion designer mom
in the lindsay lohan led remake of the
parent trap that was richardson's most
prominent screen role but she had a
prestigious stage career
it started with a touring version of the
seagull which ended in london's west end
with richardson appearing opposite her
mother renowned british actor vanessa
redgrave tv fans may know vanessa best
for her role as dr erica naughton in
niptuck opposite her older daughter and
natasha's sister jolie richardson
jolie should also be known to fans from
the parent trap era as anita in the 1996
live-action adaptation of 101 dalmatians
as you've probably noted natasha was
part of an acting dynasty her
grandfather sir michael redgrave
vanessa's father was famous for
tragedies natasha's aunt lynn redgrave
vanessa's sister was an oscar-nominated
theater superstar to round out the
family lin and vanessa's brother coryn
redgrave was a stage actor and
playwright natasha met actor liam neeson
when they starred opposite each other in
a broadway production of anna christie
she was nominated for a tony for the
role and the two later married and had
two sons together
natasha died suddenly of head injuries
sustained during a skiing trip on march
18 2009. she was 45.
in a show that made superstars out of
its six main cast members james michael
tyler managed to hold his own as one of
the most memorable side characters he
played coffee shop manager gunther and
friends for all 10 seasons appearing in
150 episodes total although he didn't
have a line for his first 33 appearances
tyler originally landed the role because
he knew how to work the fancy espresso
machine on the central perk set not one
to take himself overly seriously after
friends he played himself in the satire
episodes which saw that version of tyler
experiencing a slightly awkward reunion
with matt leblanc who played joey on
friends also playing himself tyler loved
the experience of being in friends
although there was one drawback as he
told digital spy he was cast with very
distinctive bleached blonde hair which
added to his character's mystique but it
was originally the result of an
experiment he let one of his friends
perform which turned into weekly bleach
jobs for 10 years
tyler was diagnosed with prostate cancer
in 2018 which he didn't make public
until june of
2021. that month he announced in an
interview with nbc that the cancer had
reached stage 4 meaning it had spread to
other parts of his body he died just a
few months later on october 24 2021.
a veteran stage film and television
actor richard griffiths is known by the
masses for his portrayal of harry
potter's uncle vernon dursley while
dursley was for the most part always
cruel to the young wizard he was still a
part of harry's family and he ultimately
helped prove that the boy who lived had
a golden heart because he still cared
for the uncle who treated him poorly
outside of the harry potter series
griffiths won a slew of awards over the
course of a busy career earning
particular acclaim for his portrayal of
english teacher douglas hector in a play
called the history boys
he also starred in a variety of projects
including superman 2 gandhi sleepy
hollow king ralph hugo pirates of the
caribbean on stranger tides and the
hitchhiker's guide to the galaxy
griffiths passed away at 65 on march 28
2013 due to complications shortly after
having heart surgery
brad renfrow skyrocketed to fame at age
11 through his acclaimed work in joel
schumacher's adaptation of author john
grisham's book the client high profile
roles quickly followed and renfro made
appearances in sleepers opposite brad
pitt the informers starring kim basinger
and ghost world alongside scarlett
johansson yet as his star continued to
rise on screen renfro faced a darker
path behind the scenes one that would
ultimately see him fulfilling the sad
destiny of many child actors plunging
into a life of illegal drug use and
trouble with the law after attempting to
buy drugs from an undercover la police
officer renfro pleaded no contest to
attempted possession of heroin and spent
10 days in jail on january 15 2008 at 25
years old renfro's turbulent story
reached a tragic end when he was found
dead of an accidental heroin and
morphine overdose in his apartment in
los angeles
dana plato played kimberly drummond in
the long-running hit television series
different strokes cast alongside fellow
child stars gary coleman and todd
bridges she was catapulted to instant
stardom
to cope with the mounting pressures of
fame plato often indulged in cocaine and
marijuana off the set yet it wasn't
until she became pregnant that the
network released her from her contract
helping her trigger a downward spiral of
drugs and alcohol that included work in
adult films and a spread in playboy
magazine
she later moved to las vegas where
desperate for cash she robbed a store
for less than 200 and was bonded out of
jail by vegas entertainer wayne newton
she died at the age of 34 on may 8 1999
in her rv in oklahoma after taking a
fatal dose of lortab and valium
best known for her work starring as mel
gibson's daughter in the blockbuster the
patriot sky mccoll bartusiak was a child
actress with a promising future she made
her film debut in the cider house rules
in 1999 and starred with michael douglas
and brittany murphy in don't say a word
in 2001. she also appeared in the film
kill your darlings with true blood star
alexander skarsgard in 2006.
unfortunately bartusiak's life behind
the scenes wasn't as glamorous as fans
might have assumed and included some
dangerous drug habits that would end up
contributing to her having an accidental
overdose in 2014. according to
bartusiak's mother the young star had
also been suffering from epileptic
seizures prior to her passing which led
to the family initially believing she
choked to death before the coroner's
ruling made the tragic truth clear
before getting his big break michael k
williams was consistently cast as
one-dimensional criminals he was a young
black man in a white industry that
didn't know how to tell diverse stories
about people who looked like him also he
had a distinctive facial scar from the
time someone attacked him with a razor
something else hollywood didn't know
what to do with
william's big break came courtesy of the
wire character omar little an armed
robber who targets drug dealers and the
most feared man in a territory ruled by
violence but little wasn't a carbon copy
of those previous characters for one
thing he was openly gay in a homophobic
society that mocked gay men as weak for
another he was known to give some of his
ill-gotten gains to people in his
much-in-need community
after playing omar williams landed roles
in several prestigious series including
crime drama the night of when we rise
about the gay civil rights movement and
a recurring part as a racketeer in
prohibition drama boardwalk empire he
even got to show off his comedy skills
and community in 2019 he appeared in ava
duvernays when they see us as the father
of one of the wrongfully accused central
park five
in 2020 he was nominated for his fifth
emmy for the hbo series lovecraft
country williams died at the age of 54
on september 6 2021 of what was later
confirmed as a drug overdose
if you or anyone you know is struggling
with addiction issues help is available
visit the substance abuse and mental
health services administration website
or contact samhsa's national helpline at
1-800-662-help